[Music]
welcome everyone so today as you like
you already have noticed we are in a bit
unusual location we were invited by
inverto a consulting company that is
part of boston consulting group to their
cologne office yesterday evening we
arrived from munich here in cologne we
have now a full day ahead of us meeting
consultants off in virto they're going
to talk to us about procurement and
supply chain consulting as these are the
two topics that alverto part of bcg is
focusing on so stick here with me we are
not going to have a typical coffee break
in the morning as well of course so
let's get into it
hi
hi i'm laura nice to meet you hi laura
great for having me thank you
so we got ourselves the typical coffee
so welcome to another coffee break here
on my channel from learning my name is
heinrich and on my channel i want to
help you to become successful in the
first years of your career so if you're
a first time watcher of the channel on
from learning we try to talk about
consulting topics career topics
especially focused on people in the
first years of their career so if this
is something that interests you feel
free to subscribe today we are going to
talk specifically about consulting
consulting ed and verto about
procurement and supply chain consulting
before we do that let's start with a
little introductory round that we know
to whom we are talking here
can you just tell us a little bit about
your role at inverto yes sure so i'm
laura i'm a project manager here at
inverto and i'm focusing on the
area of procurement retail and consumer
goods and as a project manager you're
responsible for leading operatively the
project teams and also exchange with the
client in regards to the strategic path
of the project cool
i'm daniela i'm also a project leader at
inverter at the vienna office and i'm
focusing on the industries
healthcare
retail and consumer goods so let's start
with your background what did you do
before working in consulting actually i
have a phd in astrophysics
okay that's micro might say
well i understood
so what about you what is your
background what did you do before
consulting yes so i always worked in the
retail business and in the consumer
goods business in various firms in
germany and also in other countries um
and i have a fashion and consumer goods
background in that sense so what is your
most memorable moment at inverto so i
think actually at the annual conference
where we were just in france and that
was a great experience to meet everyone
in person after this long cover time and
see how big tall or small everyone was
so not sure if this question really
applies in the current situation but can
you tell us about your most exotic
project location of course so as you
said right now we are a lot in home
office but usually inverto has
projects all over the world and actually
what i what is really nice right now is
that i can be on five continents in one
call so i really enjoy that but of
course i'm also looking forward to
then be on site at the client
[Music]
so i can say at least for myself that
before joining consulting i probably did
not even know what a buying organization
other client would do and for sure also
not what procurement consulting would be
all about so this is exactly what we are
now going to talk about thankfully
daniela prepared a couple of flip charts
for that and will enlighten us so i'd
say let's get over to the meeting room
to dig into it sure
so let's start with the basics what is
procurement and supply chain management
consulting all about
usually we divide it into direct and
indirect articles so direct articles is
everything that flows into the
production of of the article itself that
the that the client produces
so for example if you have a clothing so
it would be everything that is used to
produce this clothing like the buttons
like the fabric and so on
indirect on the other hand is everything
that is indirectly used to produce this
article which can be energy or all
utilities or it can also be logistics or
something like that
so let's look at the different types of
projects that you would do as a
procurement consultant so what are the
different variations that you actually
do in your job
sure
i prepared here a small flip chart so
let me start with the most common
project which is
reducing costs
so
clients often
come to us and they want to reduce their
costs to have a higher margin or simply
to be more
competitive at the market
so this is for sure one of our most
common projects
then
we also have
clients that come to us because they
want to change something in their
procurement organization this often
happens after merger and acquisitions or
also for clients that want to do an ipo
for example
we have clients that not only want to
change something in their procurement
but they want to change the whole
end-to-end structure so they want to
have a closer look at their supply chain
to improve their efficiency and
maybe also to improve their lead times
then in previous years
digital became more and more
important also for our clients also in
procurement this is why inverto
founded our own digital uh data science
department where
they come in into our projects if they
are needed
for a lot of our clients design to value
is also important so changing their
product to maximize their impact on the
customer so really
customer focused
product design
and last but not least
we have the new clients for example
sustainability became very important in
in the past few years for all of our
clients so this is also topics that we
are focusing on
so now that we learned what procurement
consulting is all about i'm glad to have
laura here with me we will not talk
about what it's actually like to be a
consultant on a team how a typical team
is set up on such a consulting project
okay so what we can see here is a
typical project structure in regards to
the staffing and the people we're having
on our projects so at the first level um
we have the managing director or the
so-called senior partner which is there
to hold basically the relationship to
the client and is responsible for the
whole project yeah and here by the way
for those of you who have not seen it
yet earlier this year we did a video
with managing director lars he is an md
in the inverto munich office and he was
inviting us to join him for a full day
in bcg inverter munich so if you're
interested what a day in the life of a
consulting partner looks like i will
link the video somewhere above here
check it out i think it was a highly
insightful video but sorry let's
continue thank you
so what we can see on the next level
here is basically that we have an
associate director or a principal most
of the times who's also responsible for
the upward communication to the managing
director or the partner and also to
guide and steer the client in highly
strategic topics
on the next level we're having the
project lead level which is basically
staffed with a project manager or a
senior project manager or various
project managers depending on the work
streams we're working on so now that i
know that most of you are likely in the
first years of your career or maybe a
graduate thinking about joining
consulting likely you would then start
understanding on the consultant or
senior consultant level can you maybe
share a bit more details what really the
day-to-day activities of these people on
the project would be
sure
so what we usually do on our projects is
that we have certain work streams the
teams are working on
and the senior consultants are already
in the lead for those work streams
reporting to the project leads
and are also guiding and steering our
more junior colleagues the consultants
so when we look at a daily routine a
senior consultant also consultant is
having is basically that they look at
their work packages exchange with the
client teams on details of the spend and
details of the demand and cost
structures and then therefore or from
that spend analysis deriving the saving
potential
i hope you found this introduction to
procurement and supply chain consulting
insightful and if this sparked your
interest inverto is sponsoring this
video so thanks of all foster inverto
but what this means is that inverter is
hiring across all the european offices
so if you are interested in a career in
procurement consulting as well you can
check out the link in the video
description
[Music]
now we talked a lot about procurement
consulting supply chain consulting now
i'd love to also make use of the
opportunity of having you two here as
project leads at bcg and virto just to
learn a bit from you also potentially
for all the people in the firm learning
audience and maybe let's start indeed
with a project lead role because i know
from my experience in consulting that
that was a very big step up from being a
consulting to then suddenly being a
project lead
how was this experience for you and can
you maybe share a couple of tips for the
people who also in the audience so maybe
are thinking about becoming a project
lead soon what did you do to become
successful
so i think
at first so when i had my first project
the first thing i noticed that all the
responsibility suddenly is on you so the
consultants come to you senior
consultants they want to know what they
should do but also all the others come
to you so mds partners
principals because they want of course
to get all the knowledge they need for
the client so suddenly all the attention
is on you and all the other
responsibility and that's something you
need to get used to but at some point
you really like it so at least it was
for me yeah i think it's super important
to have a good structure in regards to
how you take notes how you organize
yourself in regards to emails and calls
and how you also structure the team in
regards to communication with you so as
daniela said you have to answer all the
questions
from client side from team site from
managing level in your firm
and that's where you need a really good
structure to have all the knowledge
condensed and ready on the spot when you
need it
makes a lot of sense i mean on top of
that you said it it's not only your
consultants it's not only on d but the
clients they are coming to you as well
and looking at you as a project lead and
indeed so this always feeds like the
position where just like from all
directions you're being put under
pressure
now back at all the people in the from
learning community i know several of you
are also still graduates or maybe in the
first years thinking about potentially
joining consulting and i trust you would
all be very interested to get your
insights into the interview process your
silver bullet of how to be successful
in consulting interviews so what what
tips do you have to share here
so i think in the in the moment where
you conduct the interview with the team
i think you have to be very structured
in regards to how you give your answers
that everyone can really relate to what
you're saying
and you should have prepared good
questions which are which are really
meaningful questions in that sense what
you want to know as a potentially future
consultant but also what could be
interesting in regards to the whole
conversation
and then it's also super important that
you stay authentic in the way you are so
if you're not a very strong communicator
just don't try to overdo it or anything
just stay true to yourself and just be
natural in the way that you talk
communicate and act in the interview i
think that's important
in terms of preparation maybe i give you
an overview of how our interviews are
structured
so
they usually take either a whole a
morning or a whole afternoon it starts
with an analytical test
that takes approximately an hour and
then you will have three interviews in a
row
you will have an interview with a
project manager or a senior project
manager then one with a principal and
one with an md
and you will do
one is a hr interview where you are
asked questions
one is a case interview and the last one
with the md is the one where you usually
also present part of your work so you
have time to prepare a presentation
already beforehand and you present this
presentation then to the md
in terms of preparation my suggestion
would be for the analytical test to
practice your calculation skills
so this is something
i had to experience myself too so you
think yeah multiplying dividing easy i
can do it
it's it's better to practice it
beforehand because um
it's it's not so easy to remember things
you learned 20 years ago so that would
be
one suggestion from my side
in terms of
the case so we are procurement
consulting so
i would suggest have a look at
procurement leavers
so
what are
typical levers that we apply because
it's very likely that you will get a
procurement case
[Music]
so this is now the end of our day here
today at inverto first of all thanks
again for inviting me certainly i
learned a lot i hope that it was
insightful for you as well so as always
if you have any questions also to the
inverto team feel free to leave a
comment below in the comment section
then we can have a look at it and
potentially also come back to you as
always if you took any value at all out
of this video please hit the like button
for the youtube algorithm and also
subscribe to the channel to stay up to
date on all the content again if you're
interested in procurement consulting
would like to check out the career
opportunities at inverto link to their
career page in the video description
big thanks also to all the members of
the channel thank you so much for your
contribution my name is heinrich i
release videos every single saturday on
this channel so see you again next week
this is heinrich bye bye